Screaming skull Scranton!?!?
*Girly Screeching*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to
Never Again, the demo.
Now, this is a horror game about...
Ooohhhh... don't do that, to me
I, I don't like that (mumbling)
(Door creaks loudly)
No thank you!
I got my back turned
Oh thank you! What a favor
You're so kind to me (sarcastic)
What a power saver, really a protector of the environment here
Okay well you didn't need to do that
I spent a lot of time putting those blocks in order
"There is no greater sorrow then to recall happiness in times of-"
(Gunshot)
Misery........ (ringing sound)
Geez we're starting this off with a BANG!
My inhaler.... oh okay alright
(gasping) oh ughh I can't breath..
Alright, well, then where the hell is my inhaler?
Where is my inhaler?!?
Where the hell is my inhaler?!?!?
Hello?!
In-ha-low?
Okay, well. cool
No..
You'd think I would keep that right by my bed.  Oh, is that my inhaler?
No, that's a block.  Why is there a block in there?
Get,  get out of there you block!  Do I need to spell out "inhaler"?
Cause I can't breath! Teddy bear..?  Teddy bear! Give me my god damn inhaler!!!
oh sorry, can't throw very far (mumble mumble)
Whoa okay! I'm dead! Apparently.....
[a rare silence]
What the hell is happening
uh oh
Oh, okay, well, I'm confused.  Am I dead?  Is this purgatory??
Ah, this ain't good
Where the hell is it taking me?
Hello, hi, uh, my name is Markiplier, and I have no idea whats happen--- OH
Step into the light, that's always a good sign
Oh! I'm back
Ah ok...
Take two on this one
Let me try to open up like...
((Markipoo noises))
Can I open this? Can I pull this out?
Ooo a lock?
Ooo oh!
7105!
Oh! Ahhhhh!!
God I'm gonna keep passing out
Over and over again...
Am I? Ahh ok...
Well i'm sprinting this time...
(( Markimoo noises))
((more markimoo noises))
Under my pillow?
Is that it?... AHHHH!!
It was under my pillow, where it should of been!
Where I should of looked!
((weird markimoo silence))
Stephen?...
((more weird markimoo silence))
ooo...ok well that's unfortunate...((sarcastic markimoo back at it again))
huh?
oooo....alrighty then...
aye!! bird!! ((markimoo noises))
I can't help you...
I'd rather keep you trapp-..nevermind...
You're gone now
Thought you might be((markimoo noises))
wanting to share some misery with me...but ..apparently not...
Do I need to do something with these?
Gosh darn blocks
Is that something that I need to do?(Muttering)
Because I found all of them
*Block Noise*
Can I play on the sea horse?
Ah what a good dad. 7105 this is... This is
just weird it's only three.
Seven
Thats six
Ooooonnnnneeeee
There's no oh so I'm guessing five?
Oh (Now he gets it) Seven, TEN, five.
That's probably it.
Ah not seven one oh because there is no oh so
it's seven te- ooooooh yes I'm gonna assume
this is uh. This is not the prize I wanted. BE
GONE DEMON! Oh that's creepy (Muttering) Hueugh Oh okay.
Sorry Dolly. What are you doing? Ew Don't like that at all.
hey there friend now if you just want to
turn away from me. WHY WONT YOU LOOK AT ME?
WHY WONT YOU LOOK AT MEEE? LOOK AT THE TREE!!
It's my favorite tree did you know that?
Okay you stay there have a good
nap. (Muttering) What else do we got in here?
Oooh Crumpled note?
Oooh more in-hay-low?
OH a pony book ah-oh ooo I'm very organized.
Okay well things... I've got a diary
sometimes when I'm very tired of other
people are just so want to tell
something to my mom
I've read all my thoughts in this diary
he knows everything about me it's like
it's part of me? This inhaler I almost
never let it go. Dad strictly told me
from childhood that if I s- that if it-
it is far away I could die mom attached
a rope to be worn around the neck well
okay that's good for me then I guess
Eh uh AGH agh what is that
well I don't like that. What a beautiful
day. No. I love Sundays. HE DON'T.
because I can luxuriate in my bed until noon. What
kind of word is luxuriate for a little girl?
For some reason I remember my
dreams very well on Sundays maybe it's
due to the fact that I sleep as much as
I want till the end of dream, like a movie.
Today i had a very specific dream. Usually I
see my mom traveling and meeting new
people. LIKE THAT PERSON? But today I saw Stefan. IS THAT STEFAN?
We played hide and seek and I hid in the closet in my
room. I felt something strange near my
back in the back blue hot air like from
the oven it turned around and I had
failed it in the wall of the closet
behind the closet was a cave entirely of fire.
The flame was everywhere I was
scared
suddenly something appeared from the
flame and was ready to come at me.
THAT THING? And I awoke. WHAT THE HELL?
What kind of story is that? You linguistics major
Jesus alright well alright well that's
that's. Hey is there a cave back here?
There's some kind of gate oh- knock knock anybody
back there
Shouldn't have done that I regret stepping
through the Wardrobe which whoa whoa the
shamon lie are everywhere please don't
believe your eyes this must be disappear
somewhere it will explode and die and
why are you telling me to run I usually
know that running is bad that means good
oh I don't like this I don't like this
no I don't so now you must be quiet
don't talk with anyone and someone could
be blind it couldn't be dead
you must shun
what are you talking about are you
talking that they can't see me oh gees oh thunk thunk
just get back in the wall back in the wall
Get back in the walll
well it's gonna stare that for a bit
is it getting brighter okay well that
was not fun okay I get it all right I
see I see you didn't notice the the meat
hooks
those are nice I'm just gonna go here
and luxuriate better well this squadron
is like one of them oh it's a puzzle how
about you you look through the people
get in the Hall Museum all right what
about this is even in the reflection
beep beep er did you go through the
mirror what do you see what do you see
with your elven eyes I hang you know you
know I want to name you but I really
don't because I don't think that you
should be named I guess it has a certain
charm and that it doesn't have any charm
at all
I'm gonna call you screaming skull
Scranton it screaming Scranton there you
want to grab on to screaming Scranton
there all right fine then whatever
bellowing baby Bristol hey ya know
whoa hey I didn't expect that to work
thank you screaming skull Scranton oh
we're gonna go on an adventure screaming
skull Scranton Oh
oh this is wobbly oh it's extra wobbly
hi bird I remember you from before but
you left me behind
okay I'm looking down oh all right well
this is the wobblyest bridge I've ever
done seen...geh gah. SCRANTON NOOOO. why did that happen? I have no idea but i'm dead now
did I lose screaming skull Scranton no
where are you screaming skull Scranton
Oh no! I lost him to the abyss oh what
a tragedy no one really cares damn it I lost
screaming skull scrander Wabo Wamba Oh
windy one bow you know what I think I
can forgive myself for that one because
that adventure probably should have
stopped wearily er than it shut up I
made it I'm good
I see so this has Mira is broken
bullshit oh look at this stupid what a
dumb Laura you know something tells me I
don't want to go there either without
the light because that just doesn't seem
safe
wait there's a shard of glass over there
from the mirror maybe I can get that hey
Scranto you're doing all right over
there good good
hey do the one bow later when I'm not on
you right now okay you understand me yep
do you be okay made it just fine okay
what about you ah I got wait why is
there a hand claw at me from behind this
mirror hang on wait there's there's an
piece of the mirror someone says the
mirror hide a lot of secrets in itself
if you look in the mirror for a long
time you can see your true self and
sometimes it's an indispensable helper
oh that's what the hand is it's my
indispensable helper it's the same man
that turned off the light in my room to
save my parents money on the electricity
bill okay alright you know what you
don't need to do the truffle shuffle
right here I am okay with that you just
let me by Oh let me by let me by like
you don't like you at all how about some
of this one detail you say this detail
I'll fam fixed perfectly all right I
just need to bounce
that's that's a look at the look at the
look at the there we go hello oh no I
have a crank don't do that something out
of that okay we're good we're clear
we're good good alright let's put this
in there crank the well I got there some
crank it up if you think I fucked enough
open it oh oh screaming skull sprint how
are you doing here without me
great glad to hear it screaming skull
Scranton you're doing so good in life
hey how are the kids
oh man look like you've been busy with
the family if you know what I mean okay
all right all right well hello can I
help you oh you must be the father Oh
see you've lost weight Oh God Oh miss
mr. Scranton or mr. scream
well I got that oh hello what are you
doing back there aren't you lovely
alright well you know alright
oh I don't like that even a little bit
screaming scoffs granted oh do not tell
me a fairy tale Oh what the hell
oh that was the ender oh okay all right
I guess I'm dead now okay so that is
never again the demo I don't know when
the full version is going to be released
it might be one of those things it's on
Kickstarter I have no idea but it's
really good they got a lot of elements
here that remind me of amnesia the pace
is a bit slower but I kind of like that
about it it lets you build it into it
and gives you this false sense of
security like it reminds me of into the
sleep or into the sleep bed something
does asleep you know the game about the
baby and because it's kind of told from
like a child's perspective so their
innocence kind of like paints the the
terrifying narrative in a very
interesting way and I like it so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think of this down in
the comments below I'll provide a link
to the demo because maybe maybe there's
a full version coming out soon and you
guys can find out about that too so
thanks again as always in the next video